hey there gang it's your old pals uncle
Hank and Kippy we got some big news
folks are you garbage is coming to the
gas digital network that is correct to
me an old Kippy are joining the gas
digital family baby and we could not be
more excited yeah guys this is [ __ ]
awesome and but don't worry not much is
changing if you listen to the podcast
it's still available free wherever you
listen the most 15 the most recent 15
episodes are available free on itunes on
youtube wherever you listen to podcasts
but the catalog of our you garbage will
be available on gas digital network.com
but don't you worry your little garbage
hearts ladies and gentlemen because if
you go to gas digital network.com and
use promo code a yg you know I got you
big man talk to me I get you a 14-day
free trial and you'll save a dollar 50 a
month come along as you're signed up
it's gonna be uh whoo you'd be crazy not
to sign up for that that savings right
there and this economy we can all use to
save a couple of bucks so spend it
wisely folks not only do you get the
catalog of a yg you also get the past
catalog of Legion of skanks of real ass
podcast I believe you mate with Michael
Bisping Irish goodbye Irish goodbye you
get all the shows on the network it's
gonna be [ __ ] worth it guys sign up
use promo code or a yg don't be a piece
of trash and gang don't forget to check
out the live stream every Tuesdays and
Fridays at gas digital network.com if
you want to watch it in HD high quality
sign up for the network you will not
regret it
those live streams will be out three
days where everybody else gets to see
them so you're the first one to smell
the garbage baby sign up today welcome
to another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now here are your
hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
our you garbage the show will we sit
down with your favorite comedians and
fun if they grew up classy or if their
complete trash I'm your host H totally
coming at you on yet another gorgeous
day here in Bluebell Pennsylvania fourth
of July is this weekend thinking about
doing a brisket maybe some ribs mom's
making potato salad it's gonna be some
clean living
my co-host back in the New York groove
up there in the uptown uptown Washington
Heights holdin it down keeping the block
on lock we tell you something gang not
if the holidays coming 4th of July the
next time you reach for a best pal go
ahead and make it a Kippy he tastes
great doesn't fill you up give it up for
Mike Kevin James Ryan everybody now 30%
more forehead happy to be here thanks
for tuning in
yeah back here in New York but leaving
tomorrow heading down the old Bucks
County Pennsylvania baby really gonna
hide out there while your mom's down the
shore oh yeah it's like a three-card
Monte with me dude
wherever she is I'm not you know I get
the Underground Railroad from the kurono
it's just I wouldn't go to [ __ ]
Jersey I'll pay that it's too hot down
here it's too hot in the city dude
they're laying off fireworks like it's
[ __ ] hell dude I haven't had a good
night's sleep in six weeks it's tough
but guys thanks listen if you haven't
already please make sure you rate review
subscribe on iTunes also subscribe on
YouTube the full video is available
there as well every nice guys thank you
so much a very special guest that we
have here with us today we're so happy
to have this gentleman he's been an
extremely requested get we got them you
love them you wanted them here we are
with them we known from Jump Street back
in the old Raven lounge days
Philadelphia comedy scene coming up on
the run baby is the
host of the dad meat podcast a tall
drink of water he's a good-looking kid
comes from good stock but the big
question everybody's wearing today is he
garbage I would have to guess yes give
it up for mr. Tim bodily everybody
thanks for having me boys you're leanin
yes all out of the gate out of the gate
I'm going yeah I think you guys know too
much about me already
I don't but I'll say this I wanted to I
wanted to have you on because you know a
lot of times we talk about childhood and
stuff like that but as most of the folks
out there know there are Tim but early
fans Tim's a proud father he's got his
own little family
they started the family young I remember
when we were filming Babe Ruth time
traveller eight years ago and you had
the family more extras your wife was
dead a little kids were there I was like
I bet you the butterly household is fun
I bet you there's a lot of eighties
movies a lot of snacks a lot of nerf
guns a lot of games do you do you
associate like fun for children like fun
parents almost entirely garbage through
and through right oh there's a very slim
margin that are yeah I got no shot yeah
it's rough we like Robin Williams in the
beginning of mrs. Doubtfire you got a
[ __ ] petting zoo for somebody man do
you know who I've been trying to emulate
I've been trying to be gomez addams like
weird weird guy everyone's kind of like
he doesn't you know normal people are
like put off by him but he's trying to
[ __ ] eat he's just trying to love his
kids and [ __ ] [ __ ] his wife
that's all Gomez is about and if it
weirds people out that's fine I like
that as long as you don't let the
property go the way the [ __ ] slap but
you slip a coat of paint up there I live
in a real dirtball neighborhood in
Philly so you're from you're from the
city right you were you at your were
born and raised in the city
yeah Kensington born and raised yeah
this is what I know cuz my whole
family's from Kensington as well we were
tonight when they we were the only ones
that got a couple of bubbly mom and dad
got a couple of bucks and made it up to
out of the suburbs but I'm very well
versed in Kenzo to them
you know what I mean how would you sum
it up for people that have just no
familiarity with the region
I mean it's shockingly awful I mean you
think about the worst part of the city
it's it's getting you'll still be I've
never taken a bus out there can't
remember why and I'm your doctor
that would be like there would be like
places where a bridge was supposed to be
but there'd be no bridge yeah yeah like
the other land around it had like a
bridged handline a lot of former
infrastructure yeah a lot of rundown
buildings lot of you know lots with high
grass windows if you're if you're a
Dominican dude the ultimate come up is a
house next to a house that burnt down
right you mow out the grass you throw
down some pavers you've got a private
driveway for you know whatever whatever
you're lugging stuff around in you know
I mean yeah bro they don't they don't
send a lot of code inspectors L&I is in
swinging through to check to make sure
there's girders or anything yeah a lot
of cease and desist orders now there's
no hard hats there's no tamales dude it
is pretty it's pretty much I used to me
it wasn't a very I mean it was always
kind of dicey but it was like a very
blue-collar
I think historically it was like it was
like a solid working-class neighborhood
there's an elevated train that runs
through it I don't know who ever thought
those were a good idea because it's like
let's make a permanent night in a poor
neighborhood so it's like all right cool
you've basically made a crime garden
that's you know 20 miles long through
the city and yeah it's just you know
things went the way they went and now
it's I pretty sure it's the heroin
capital of the East Coast yes I would I
would I would argue maybe even the
country like number one and something
baby come on yeah right let's go let's
go put that on the [ __ ] high school
football banner let them run through
are you so you're still in Kensington
yeah I'm getting out any day now
just trying to find some property why
are you still there windows dude what
are you doing glutes what wasn't like
when you when you were growing up there
though how many of us did your parents
have between them there were one two
three four just five of us folks just
for the listener out there never want to
start a sentence between them if you're
playing along at home I was counting on
my fingers not if you could see that
yeah and it was like it was shitty but
like it was shitty in a way where you
could be as a child you could be deluded
into thinking it was normal you know
what I mean there's no Little League and
riding your bike and [ __ ] like that yeah
yeah like there's like we had like the
PAL League's and [ __ ] like that for free
sports for the kids and like you just
didn't know that you were living in
[ __ ] abject poverty
wait the Police Athletic League yeah
that was our sports I don't think I even
knew of a place with a travel team until
like I saw one on TV as like a teenager
it was like we what you know just you
don't just play every sport at the
overused playground down the street yeah
those playgrounds after dark get dicey
to grow that was actually how I ended up
developing a sense of humor was I was
just constantly trying to make like the
I guess let's call him the older kids I
was constant trying to make them laugh
so that they would protect me from the
other kids my age because I was a
[ __ ] dork you know what I mean so
like if we had to like scrape by some of
the older kids that were just looking to
beat ass I would try to crack a couple
jokes
say something silly about myself and
eventually I was like when someone came
looking for me they'd be like whoa he's
you know that fat key it's kind of funny
leave him alone it's so weird that
that's the own that's like the
universally respected thing with poor
people is a sense of humor if you can
break balls like do my whole family it's
like we just get around we just drink
cheap beer and just make fun of each
other it's insane it's the only
affection that I truly understand yes
yes if you're not being made fun of at
like a
like if this like if you like my cousin
brings a husband around and no one [ __ ]
with them it's like because nobody likes
yeah yeah you should crave that if you
if you're around [ __ ] poor people or
dirt balls or whatever and they're not
ripping into you the second day meet you
it's because they're not feeling it 100%
you got a fire a warning shot and see if
they turn you go across the bow of the
boat to see what happens exactly dude
otherwise it's you know sorry dude it's
not where that can backfire though your
mom corners you why don't you say to
Barry
yeah but parents have no they have no uh
what do you call it jurisdiction over
this kind of stuff like they they care a
little bit about manners but for the
most part it's like you just let us walk
and bawl out dudes like meat in the
basement and just you know [ __ ] Fight
Club this thing out that just goes back
to their brain from when you were kids
and you were just doing wrestling moves
on each other in an unsupervised bedroom
and every once in a while they come up
with like stops that guys come on all
right cool you were in the coat room it
went down in the coat room just wearing
swishy pants to a fancy party and
sliding across the floor as fast as you
could oh you're rooting through some
pockets see what's up so your house in
Kensington wasn't like the standard
three-bedroom this is the hide this is
the house I grew up in I took it over
from my dad when he finally got out of
the neighborhoods how many my cousins
the [ __ ] box is getting checked here
I know and I trust me I'm aware of it
yeah my dad got out and I was like this
would be a great opportunity I could fix
up my dad's old house I could pay off
the mortgage I good knows coming on a
charter school for my kids so my kids
aren't really you know what I mean well
they just good they started out in a
kindergarten in a Philly public school
in this neighborhood and luckily like
the kindergarten was separate from like
the rest of the school otherwise I might
have fewer kids right now and I was the
weed they were selling iodine bag we're
trying to play people over the weed was
heroin so I got them into it like a
charter school again I'm just I dude I'm
trying to in my mind I'm justifying it
like I'm saving money to provide a
better life for my kids I got into
charter school and I realized that where
I was sending these kids every day
at their old school it was like an
abandoned prison the way that it was run
the way it was maintained but I think
they're good now no big deal we're
almost out yeah bounce back no harm no
foul
Wow but yes I grew up around here I I
you know I was threw up in the house
with here my only my sister is a full
sibling the rest kind of came and went
my younger sister so we we were pretty
tight we're still like best friends you
still talk to the outside siblings yeah
I talked to my my older half-brother
he's like a full he's basically a full
and then the other team we're good I'm
good let's back this up break down this
dynamic for me what do you want to start
your mom and your dad both were married
before correct yes and they both had
kids yeah yeah they both had prior kids
how many your mom have my mom had two
older than me and my dad had one older
than me so those are my three
half-brothers I don't talk to the ones
they're all brothers yeah yeah those
being some rough characters yeah yeah
there there was actually and when they
would like have to kind of like Co like
step single sibling mingle it would get
kind of dicey and I remember one night
where one of my brothers from my mom had
to be restrained by everyone in the
house because he was trying to run out
of the door with a kitchen knife to go
after one of my brothers from my dad's
friends so there's it's funny it's a
funny memory to me now Christmastime
baby Christmastime makes us although
nuts yeah dude I was just with all my
cousins for this last weekend and same
thing there was a fight that had to be
you know and everybody had a push
everybody away it's just so well like
it's so normalized through my family
where I'm like for like what are some
lights my voice what do you guys do
tomorrow like you'll just [ __ ] say
what's up and you know keep it moving
see you at Christmas you know grab a
breakfast Sammy like a high sign like
all right we got to pull the cord it's
getting a little dicey you know I mean
it depends how much alcohols involved
for sure like that you know they'll
definitely blow by the checkpoints if if
they're feeling rowdy enough if it goes
and there's a fight then
the mornings gonna be a little bit
awkward sure believe that we've had a
couple of you know it's a big mistake
for a garbage family doing the brunch
after a wedding because a lot of [ __ ]
[ __ ] happens in the wee hours of the
night at that wedding and then you show
up to the brunch and certain people
aren't looking each other in the eye
this one left early this one's not
talking about one dude brunch after a
wedding with you a millionaire the
wedding ends you have to vacate the VFW
that was one of my questions have your
new whole wedding at a VFW
I've been eighths of Columbus no Knights
of Columbus is also a little bit less
urban than me VFW's it was everything
was at the VFW and we only stopped going
to this VFW when there was a shooting in
front of it and we're like I we're gonna
stop looking at the VFW I'll tell you
what though they know their way around a
[ __ ] meatball in a mash bro there's I
haven't I haven't been served food at an
event in my adult life that has ever
compared to a roast beef sandwich that
from above their nose just [ __ ] wet
meat that you're scooping out with a
spoon you like gotta like dry it you
know what I mean before you put it on
the roll don't stir no flavor
I got a stale kaiser roll damn a bad
salad with warm ranch dressing dude
lettuce no croutons all right so growing
up as far as you could tell it was your
mom your mom and your dad they stayed
together the whole time you were growing
up right until about high school yeah oh
then they split up yeah cuz I met your
dad before he's oh he's an ass-kicker
dude he's the best guy in the world and
he's the he's the only reason that I'm
not you know any one of these questions
Gary
well yes Larry but he looks I get how
his size could be scary yeah
sweetest fell a heart of gold and sure
when I met him no he was wearing a
wife-beater is that possible a black
wife beater I didn't say he was classy
he's he's not a [ __ ] rockefeller you
know I mean he's from Kensington okay
he's got a pair of Reebok Classic coming
across as like a like a motorcycle guy
yeah he's a well so if if you [ __ ] how
do i phrase this you
he's kind of like a poverty gearhead
where it's like well the truck broke
again I have to fix it like that you
know I mean the dirty hands his whole
life and what did he do for a living
he was a he owned a series of print
shops that price failed for different
like you could blame other people
reasons but he never was that kind of
guy and he always just you know eyes
forward kept working hmm
so as long as I've known him rough hands
always dirty always smells like some
kind of chemical never selling work
that's very respectable for scandal and
your mom what was there was her story
she's a lunatic I know yeah I haven't
talked to her turn over a couple of
rocks you find that Bank here we go
I haven't been super public about this I
I'm like I'm constantly like online and
talking and putting [ __ ] out and it's
all personal but I haven't really
spilled any anything on her I haven't
talked to her in about 10 years and she
she tried to do she tried to pull off
the ultimate in white trash she tried to
get a disability claim for life that
wasn't quite you know what I mean
and what kind of slip and fall but it
wasn't you know anyway it didn't go her
way and along the way she got kind of
you know she started to like the candy
they were given her and she was just
like just a series of bad decisions and
like you know so she actually got
injured from do it it was like a minor
like a back thing at work and then she
was like dude I'm getting paid forever
and we were all kind of like like we
didn't have like the cushion to go
through that kind of process know what
I'm saying she didn't go into it like as
a scam like all right Tim you're gonna
drive me to work and then you're gonna
spill some ice on the floor we get to
the top of the steps and then I'll spill
a coffee and you'll push me yeah so like
a step like yeah like a hair back from
that it was like yeah my back hurts from
that thing at work and then it was like
just dollar signs in the eyes and that
dude that yeah it destroyed us it killed
us but I mean obviously not you we're
pushing on we're you know yeah you got a
sweet setup there what are you talking
about that's a whole more we got a sweet
setup kids are in charter schools
goddamn but early yeah well I cuz I dude
I said I got your mom's fraud you got a
set of headphones come on
I'm more garbage adjacent like I know
what I'm supposed to be I know how is
supposed to turn out but I said I had a
very uh kind dad who kind of kept me on
the right track and and I was also a
[ __ ] dork like if I didn't have Super
Nintendo I'd probably be dead from
heroin but yeah I'm not gonna [ __ ]
hear you know I'm not gonna question it
too much sure keep your head down and
keep working like your dad you know oh
yeah I'm self-aware
I'm the Johnny Five of garbage your
enemy do not dismiss out I'm an autistic
robot that should have been [ __ ] a
junkie it's fine how much younger is
your sister than you like three years so
you guys grew up in there together yeah
yeah just fightin fighting constantly is
it normal for brothers and sisters to
fistfight constantly growing up or is
that just garbage I couldn't speak on it
but yeah it's pretty garbage usually
raises that raises a tough girl and a
not a tough son sure that's your
sparring partner I would say that's
exactly how we ended up yeah she's taken
you dude whoa so a sister in a sibling
fight has a handicap because if you go
if the brother goes a hundred percent
yeah you're [ __ ] dude you're you're
punished man I'll give me the [ __ ]
Super Nintendo controllers by getting
your ad you're getting your ass beat by
your dad yeah yeah so if the sister goes
a hundred percent you the brother still
gets in trouble you know what I mean so
she was like weapons free and I'm like
what are the what's the limitations on
this what's the rules of engagement
yeah she [ __ ] me up dude my younger
sister used to beat the [ __ ] out of me
did your dad hit did your mom or dad
smack you around yeah my mom would pop
us every once in a while my dad I don't
think ever once hit me never needed to
dude he was he was all Karen sounds like
a real straight [ __ ] shooter stroke
yeah yeah I mean they he it has to be
bad luck that he's not a [ __ ] you
know capitalist winner in life or maybe
just like he doesn't like any of the
negative association with you know
taking what you want from the world and
then you know he's like a monk that's
what he is he's a [ __ ] monk
Kensington monk Kensington
you make it sound like shaft walking
runnin different solving crimes yeah
well yeah he's incorruptible I do yo I
died you the neighborhood to keep my
kids in line though like so yeah yeah
I'm kind of a fun dad ready - I've we
get around around here huh but when
we're having a good time come on
my daughter's 12 dude and when she comes
to me with like what 12 year olds like
on the Internet she'll but she'll tell
me about like youtuber interpersonal
drama and I'm like okay let's go for a
little ride mm-hm and we'll take a drive
like if I take like a half a mile radius
around my house it's like you're looking
at human zombies like decaying on the
street yeah I'm like what do you think
the youtubers what do you think they
would think about this kind of stuff huh
you want to see a little bit of reality
yeah and yesterday I saw a lady she was
made conversation and like casually like
flipping her hair this is this is the so
here let me set the scene for you
there's an elevated train that I
mentioned earlier and right now because
they cleaned out like a homeless
encampment around a train station
somewhere they closed down like a bunch
of tent cities in Philly they're all
congregating just in a corridor under
this elevated train and it's the
bleakest [ __ ] you've ever seen it's like
imagine if like like rubble in
Afghanistan also had junkies on it so
that's why I'm watching this ladies just
tell a story and like flipping her hair
talking to a friend and if you looked at
her shins her shins both had like
gangrenous holes in them her legs were
rotting off of her body and she's like
yeah I told him like what her shins look
like yeah uh you ever see like a boss
fight in a video game where like if the
boss lets you know where they're
vulnerable
what's sure yeah both of her legs were
her weak spot and they were like
flashing red and I'm just like okay cool
let's tell me more about you know how
these youtubers want to know who's the
best that makeup or it'll sure sure sure
Jesus Christ it but it might be a little
bit harsh now that I'm saying it out
loud no yeah it's like scared straight
you know well it sounds like you're
doing good
they're in the neighborhoods are doin
fantastic I love so high you know bro I
don't let any of this [ __ ] hold me back
I don't care I'm fully aware for sure I
think you obviously you came I think
from not your dad seems like a straight
shooter but like you were came from a
garbage environment for sure you know
definite not the best environment you
like you're like the phoenix that rose
up he's still in it what are you talking
about he's yeah I know but he's got a
good life for himself he's married got
some kids he's not pulling a
slip-and-fall scam you know enemies that
is got a good head on his shoulder I'm
optimistic I might blow out of this I
might pull out of this I'm putting my
money on butterly yeah thank you you
means a lot just have someone say that
you already mean dude what are you
talking dude the kids a [ __ ] fighter
come on it's true I keep messing my kids
are sweet too by the way I know I see
and I see pics on the gram and
everything this is like we can't let
them out of the house anymore
like the neighborhood decline so much
that we just get them inside so now I'm
wondering like why is there to be a
Netflix series about me someday because
how I had the race there like a shed
family yeah like Hanna or whatever yeah
I chained in two radiators at night this
is for their safety
all right just he taught them to kill at
an early age
I got them all in GG learning how to
fight they'll be fine thorn do you
really yeah not bad jujitsu that's
pretty you know Ronnie you butchered
whatever you try to see dude Jitsu
jujitsu yeah there you go all right
let's give it a some [ __ ] are you
garbage questions here mr. Tim but early
like I said I'm fascinated by the but
early family now I just want that on
record that I want to hear a little bit
about that too so maybe we can go back
and forth a little bit all right happy
to hit him with some of the basics Kip
what do you think sure let's do it all
right so you got now go go go you lived
in the same house growing up correct
you're in that house now you made a lot
of improvements to it some improvements
you made some very interesting what's
the what was the bathroom like growing
up did you have a curtain did you have a
glass to jab Oh curtain
yeah the bathtub er just a shower there
was a bathtub but I don't remember ever
being able to fit in it but that might
have been a fat thing Jesus Christ how
fat were your little bro I was probably
your size now when I I was a fat boy
dude I used to my older brothers my
older half-brothers they used to make to
make their friends laugh they would make
me make a frog face with my fat tits and
belly like if I pulled my [ __ ] kills
yourself we have both of you you one
went the other way one went the other
Folie think that's a good bit but I
think now maybe changed my life for the
better
always like that's my clothes on the
road do you know how many truffle
shuffles I had to do was old tell you do
you pull it makes you bully proof cuz
someone bigger is gonna want to keep
laughing at that you know what I mean
it's true how did you get so big what
was your Pollak our ocean leaving no
yeah my parents didn't know anything
about nutrition so it was just like they
trust you to feed yourself and I was
like alright well I will trust myself to
eat [ __ ] pop-tarts six hours a day
that was your move that's what you
deaths yeah it was your poison so much
wreck fish that was your heroin for sure
yeah for sure a sweet breakfast that
might my oh my dad's also an incredible
cook so we had like crazy good
home-cooked meals every single night
what's a sweet breakfast just like only
pastries or something not like you know
eggs not proteins and healthy fats I've
never heard that that's trash I like a
sweet sweet or savory sure sweetness
[ __ ] and I started rolling back in his
head there was an alternative literally
the first question on my list is have
you ever gone to a wedding at a VFW or
Knights of Columbus by have you ever
been to the Pennsylvania State Fair no
no dude that's above
I would say that's above my station or
maybe maybe I did you know what we did
do a lot at the racetrack in Bensalem
yeah D we didn't get we didn't get that
far in north of the city very often we
did a lot of Clements in Park when I was
a kid oh my god
Fleming Clement J Park I have to be back
since I was a kid is that really is it
is it that well I know it's bad now but
was it bad but when we were kids they
test IEDs I remember in kindergarten we
went there and I had a we had like a
yarn nametag where you wrote your own
name it would be useless to identify me
by the way if I was that a petting zoo
so I was like oh there's animals that
aren't pigeons here this is fancy
you know what I mean and just pigeons
painted a different color
yeah just says goat with a sign
livestock I guess a baby goat ate my
nametag off of me like first of all that
was the safety of all I was a petting
zoo
it reached soon it ate my name tag off
and I always thought of it as like a
charming memory and there's just it is
at that age it is but like looking back
like dude I love to love to good petting
zoo what growing up and that was
actually it depends something stay fair
they had one and me and my buddy gave
the pot-bellied pig bubblegum he just
sat there and chewed it for an hour damn
straight we [ __ ] it was the funniest day
of my life did you guys take turns
pretending it was talking who the [ __ ]
would he was singing it hey man let's
give the pig some gum [ __ ]
I don't know well they used to put the
quarters in and they had like to feed
that would come out of the like the
gumball slots you know it was like a
gumball machine with a big seed yeah
with like goat feet or whatever it was
just like brown food that they eggs they
would eat mm-hmm
and we ran out our quarters or whatever
we had a couple you know some bubble
tape on us or something a [ __ ] coward
Izzy hide them up with a hubba bubba
let's do this
their [ __ ] rules wowthat's [ __ ] let
me Tim partial tough though that's
that's a tough luck yeah like we we
weren't brazen enough to play pranks on
animals that close I'm sorry but but we
enjoyed it all the same they had oh oh
they had the world's oldest wooden
roller coaster or something like that
and I don't know if it's still
operational I think I was near the end
of them decommissioning a ride yeah
that's I remember god I remember going
to places with wooden roller coasters
and I was like what my dad like leg get
on it's safe I'm like dude get the [ __ ]
out of here whatever I think we saved
doctor go to Sisk Six Flags one summer
and when I went on like a most people
have a college fund you have a great
adventure I only found out like five
years ago that there are beaches that
you have to pay to be on yeah [ __ ] that
Beach tag [ __ ] yeah I don't pay to be on
the butt like yeah I didn't know there
was anything other than North Wildwood
mmm-hmm that's why I spent my whole
[ __ ] that's very quarantine but the
last three months was North Wildwood
whoa it is a different world down there
baby
wait so that in the preseason it wasn't
even open yet no it's not open well it's
kind of open the board with some of the
things on the boardwalk are open but
yeah I went down there and the beginning
of March and I just came back like last
week I was down this weekend the shirt
airbrushes are showing up for pre-season
practice dude it's like they still got
like the basketball game would like to
beat it with the Benetton rims where the
basketball barely fits I'm like
nothing's changed in this place in
[ __ ] 25 years it's frozen in time
it's incredible percent I think they had
like a laser tag place in the 90s on
there and they just update it with like
the news like now it's like a VR and
rolled ice cream place but the one thing
that changes yeah dippin dots in VR yeah
exactly
I saw off-brand dippin dot Saturday at
Walmart you trying out no and try him
out I never had dippin dots well really
now we were never allowed to get him it
was too expensive same
the 90s day were [ __ ] high you didn't
find out of a kiosk at the mall yeah my
mom took one look at that thought it was
a scam she's like okay we've met we've
never had kiosk money dude ah now the
only place we went that was kiosk was
they used to be this place in the malls
called maybe it's local but it was
called Joanne's nut house and it was
like just a candy kiosk where you buy
like candy by the pound like you know
like chocolate-covered peanuts and all
that kind of stuff and my aunt knew
somebody that worked there so we'd
literally go in like one day a year or
the whole family extended family - with
all - yeah we'd all go to the mall
together we'd Caravan up to King of
Prussia Mall hit the [ __ ] food court
do some shopping a lot of window and
then all the time we've hit Joey's not
here kicking tires of footlocker
I see myself on his pair of [ __ ] air
maxes potential customer can i yeah as
at 11 years old I would have been blown
away by getting $14 in free candy once a
year yes I'll trash your family as
though you gotta you gotta [ __ ] you
know a chocolate-covered pretzel
connecting the whole family rolls up it
was like the Lufthansa we'd walk in with
a [ __ ] suitcases just walk out like
we own the joint
dude that's trash that is a few tons of
caramel some two three pounds of corn as
they're putting Ziploc bags in your
pocket so you can fill them up for
twenty six century oh my god that is
garbage what was the name of your
grocery store growing up shopping bag oh
my god shopping bags are is that that's
regional right that's regional I think
garbage ennoble yeah shopping bags are
tough shop right is okay but the one
even I've been to the shopper ate a lot
in your neighbor but that's it that shop
right is fact
something else but yeah that that shop
writes like it's lowbrow for sure but
it's got like the comfort of like you
ever go to someone's mom mom's house and
it smells like soup mm-hmm
that's what shop right is it doesn't
dangerous it feels like you know all
right better I'm you know I better be on
my [ __ ] best behavior here
yeah shopping bag yeah that's like
Beirut hold on man
did you hear the way my mom rolled off
his tongue is that what you called your
grandma my mom uh no my my mom was
Graham I had Graham but rest in peace
dude who's your mama shout-out to Graham
no I never said my mom dude that's
that's for that's to make everybody else
more comfortable we said grandma okay
because that was like the fanciest thing
about me I guess when I heard other kids
saying like mom and pop up I was like or
like her nanny and call your grandmother
a pet name what are you [ __ ] the
loser
yeah no I completely agree with you
right saying grandmother made me feel
normal you know what you say Momo when
you did what do you exploit it because
I'm not trying I'm not putting on airs
anymore do you know I I don't need to
Church up my [ __ ] whole my destitute
grandmother's anymore dude they were
well mom that's great yeah I can't stand
people say [ __ ] like meemaw
get the [ __ ] out here we got a couple of
those around yeah have you ever have you
ever worked in a supermarket
yeah first job Acme ah ah mine too all
right as a bagger mm-hmm and as a bagger
you want it you want a [ __ ] garbage
job overnight shelf stocker oh my god
dude a zodiac because Jesus Christ it's
so true it's so true I used to write so
I'll put a pin in that my family owns a
construction company that works that
fixes that shop right in on our Mingo or
what mmm and we would have to go in
overnight because people from the
neighborhood would come in and read
about the sinks and the toilets for the
copper so they like that's that's the
level of poverty and scumbag
well we would have to go in overnight
and you
would see those dudes stocking the
shelves and they are dude those guys are
cut from another [ __ ] cloth a lot of
meth a lot of mountain dew
I remember model here and eye contact
they were very uh they're very they had
specific opinions about the box cutters
that they used and they always wanted to
talk about it that was the main thing I
picked up from those guys Jesus a lot of
a lot of not being at work because you
were arrested
uh oh my big thing though was that my
acne they didn't clean the bakery at
night so there was always like cookies
and [ __ ] left in it you know what I mean
like the cookies that were supposed to
get thrown out so I would constantly
just do a lap I'd like put some [ __ ]
chips on the shelf
do a lap grab a cookie so it was just
like eight hours overnight of just
eating flour and sugar and then I would
get home with like 8:00 in the morning
and [ __ ] crash on it that's did you
have another job where that was your
only job that was yeah that was my only
job until I got I got into IT that's to
choose the work to work the graveyard
shift is a [ __ ] wheat if you have to
do it because you have like kids you
know if I wore one days and that nights
sure I'll get you that but if you're
just like well I'm kind of a night guy
you're a [ __ ] creep yeah you're a
graveyard
my choice by choice he is he was born
and he could have stayed better I'm a
reformed graveyard shift guy well I
thought about it right it was my first
job like the summer after high school
and it was very clear I was never going
to college so I I was a part-time
[ __ ] grocery bagger and I'm there's
no next step so all I was doing was I
was imagining myself at 65 years old
like well did I save enough money from
bagging groceries at all also no one
teaches you about ambition and like
goals and that kind of [ __ ] like it was
just okay you didn't die and you didn't
get addicted to anything there you have
a clear winner record yet like I was the
[ __ ] white sheep and I know I I
probably should have just become a
[ __ ] cop or something but what I was
a [ __ ] dork I I knew enough about
fixing [ __ ] computers that now no now
without ever going to college I'm like I
have a
[ __ ] sweet IT job yeah man so I guess
you garbage adjacent man the fibers from
the ashes
exactly kippis on your side buddy I like
this well I mean I know I literally I
know what you came from and I know that
it's like you know the fact that you're
even where you are isn't a [ __ ]
accomplishment this is this is what
[ __ ] dead meat is literally about
every single episode is just about
waking up every day saying I am a fat
[ __ ] gay [ __ ] boy
let's see what we could do with it yeah
it's fine movin and shakin I like it
alright let's see
anyone in your family ever collect state
quarters I just use the money now what
do you mean he's a good kid he rose up
from the accident I know what it's like
to be in that neighborhood look at a
mighty job meanwhile how did you guys
take you guys take two dollar bills
dude I asked that in the not so not so
distant past I've asked that question
from do you remember what your way of
dollars came out oh yeah do I take down
of my house yeah I found a folding like
display booklet for the state quarters I
had that exact one turn it upside down
shook it out and yeah I found ten of the
second with Julia dollars and even even
now as a 34 year old man a part of my
brain was like these the first ten
dollars that I'm gonna use to get out of
this [ __ ] you know anything like
that's still that's a part of my brain
any money that I find that isn't taxed
I'm like I'm gonna start a new life
basically it's a savings bond he's wait
yeah and I let this baby mature why that
was such that's such a garbage thing
it's integrating you to be like these
quarters are gonna be worth that's
having no idea of how money works
economies
Aaron see nothing you're just going to
babies oh that's yet beanie but
collecting this year from McDonald's to
like these are gonna be worse yeah dude
uh oh my god that was hard to get out of
my brain like especially like when you
hear that [ __ ] as a kid and then you
want to like collect pokemon cards we I
my parents never bought me one pokemon
card I I don't think that they ever work
in a game value I was never like dude
I'm gonna day trade these when I'm older
but yeah what's that called arbitrage
where you just like here at Stratton but
early we like to do oh God
there was this is the worst possible
version of this when I was a kid did one
of the cool things that we did was we
explored abandoned factories and
warehouses and [ __ ] like you'd break a
window we don't say like a dry rotted
door he would just like mule-kick it
until I was big enough to get through
and me and I me and this [ __ ] kid who
is now dead from heroin we found a bunch
of the the ratcheting clamps that tie
[ __ ] down on the back of a flatbed truck
yeah he convinced me he's like dude we
gotta flip these you how much does he
wanted hang one of these things like 50
bucks and we found like a bunch of him
in an abandoned warehouse so I was like
making I oh god this is so [ __ ]
stupid I was like making plans with this
dude I was like dude alright first of
all we're gonna need a way to get them
all out of here at once
okay once we transport them we needed a
safe place to keep them so we were like
looking at like areas near railroad
tracks that we could leave these without
someone like stealing them or a [ __ ]
pissing on them and then I [ __ ] told
my dad about it I was like hey Dad I
want to say yeah I want to cut him
before this thing takes off don't let
you wet your beak a little bit you know
what I mean hey Dad he got 12 grand and
15 minutes I got an idea keys do a
pickup truck I was like twelve years old
and I was like dad just say yo man we
might have a little bit of money coming
our way
do you [ __ ] I need you to understand
that this is not the joke version of
this story dude this [ __ ] sucks
holy [ __ ] oh yeah I picture putter Lee's
dad coming in from a long day work hands
all greasy just just fix the [ __ ]
family car he's sitting there like a
cigar and a cognac like dad things are
different now I don't know if you heard
I found some ratchet classy ratchet
clamp futures recently we're gonna be
rich oh my god dude that isn't garbage
DNA right my dad extracted me from the
planet he's our daddy you walked away
yeah and then he was like on top of that
actually this is a solid move he was
like please stop going into that same
abandoned building found the [ __ ]
clamp come up also found a bunch of
discarded porno VHS covers breath oh yes
the covers yeah just the covers which
was good enough because that it
eliminated the risk of finding a VCR and
using it yeah I mean yeah I don't know
if you've ever tried to seek really use
a VCR in a row home oh yeah that's not
good
especially when you were winded and fast
forward I'm like a [ __ ] like an
editor yeah and your parents are like
sitting at the dining room table looking
upstairs like that thing's been going
for like 45 minutes you're trying to
find the one thing that you want over
and over again you ever have just the
just the VHS rewinder and absolutely not
damn talking about privilege the air
broke my body had gone I walked at my
[ __ ] head exploded when he busted
that thing out to return a movie I was
like what the [ __ ] that is that is
actually pretty that's high-level
garbage when you're when you own a
device that just makes returning rented
VHS you're because you think it's good
that's the garbage thing is like oh this
I need this yeah you read it by the
front door yeah see what Ricky Bobby
would buy you know what I mean looks
like that can that kind of trash if you
had real money you'd be paying someone
to rewind your movies exactly you just
pay the feet drop it off [ __ ] whatever
dude I got it I got 99 cents mm-hmm
wasting my time rewinding a [ __ ]
movie [ __ ] all right what do you got
that so
Kame have you ever owned a peel box no
no that's that's uh again dude any added
expense outside of the realm of
possibility for me actually do you like
and although now I do realize that peel
boxes are for trash I just was a couple
of weeks during that one good was ever
sent or received from a p.o box well
yeah I always saw them on like like when
you would order [ __ ] on TV I'd see peel
boxes there so I was like oh that's a
business thing you don't need a plug-in
peel box I thought for the for the
buckle business ID so I actually had to
go I had to retrieve mail from the post
office a couple weeks ago and I took my
twelve-year-old with me and there was a
long line obviously and we're social
distancing so it's moving slow you're
you're standing in there for a long time
and on top of seeing two [ __ ] sleepy
heads falling asleep standing up just
the it the people cycling in and out
checking their p.o box and like slamming
it shut cuz there was nothing in it my
check they're waiting on something yeah
yeah you could feel the intention of
whatever they're expecting again though
I sim bug my daughter to this I'm like
look at this dude this could all be
yours if you just make terrible
decisions
keep it up y'all [ __ ] peel box yeah
you got a peel box a [ __ ] one sandal
every prototype have you have you ever
gone to a scrap yard to find a part for
your car man I need to right now and I'm
planning on doing it but I'm afraid to
do it what do you need
I heard a new bumper for Raya my wife's
car that's an easy pickup out of scrap
know that it's a it's a it's actually
not a bad car it's a Volvo from 2011 so
it's pretty fancy for me waiting for you
bro
they can sense that I'm not fully one of
them I do that's only such a fear of
mine when I walk home like they know I'm
not one of these
guys there's no huh you don't need a
whole new engine yeah
so a lot of my dealings with like [ __ ]
that should come second nature like I
should very easily and I know how to fix
a thing or two right I can't go to a
[ __ ] a pick out part place because
I'm just like I'm gonna get there gonna
be like a look at this [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's gonna be a thing and I just don't
want them head I don't want the
attention but it sure dude that that
happen to me it's a wedding
door in quarantine I went out a while
with so I'm like ow killing time down
here I'm like I'll go fish there was a
fishing rod in the garage so I went out
fishing but then I'm like I gotta find
Bay and I was like yeah I need bait like
well what are you going for my god here
we go this is a [ __ ] thing and then I
get it out there fish and some guy comes
up goes are they biting I'm like here we
go now I gotta talk to you like a bad
FBI agent yeah you just I don't have the
answers you're looking for using what
are you talking I'm like dude I'm just
getting out of the house just I'm gonna
leave you stay here I threw it out twice
at Casa de twice brought it back in and
the conversation I was like I gotta go
oh man I supported me wonders like do
those people would just want to talk
yeah I mean and that's just their way
sure
for sure and like I get it man imagine
what that's like that's like me going to
like a baseball game and like talking
about baseball to the guy next to me
like I just see that play like he's
talking to me about fishing Martin
standing on the rocks fishing that's not
out of this world you know but like
that's like a poor people defense
mechanism like everyone's got you know
everyone's got like a grift to them
everyone there's a second what are you
missing while he's just talking to you
for in a friendly way yes yeah so you
grow that's ingrained in you as your as
you grow up and then everyone everyone
it's like what's your what's your
ulterior motive here dude how are you
gonna [ __ ] me on this show and it's it
sucks because you know that's probably a
guy who raises people that way and now
when he just tries to be friendly with a
guy at the pier he's like another guy
just [ __ ] hold his line in and say yo
cuz what's up yeah man that's so true my
mom is so weary of everything I always
thought it was like you know like it's
like very cat like Irish guys look like
fear driven to like everything
don't look at the get you dude
everything's that's how they get you
it's so feared you're falling fully you
always turning into his mom every time I
talk to me but what about this and what
about the killer Wollaston what about
that it's I don't I'm friendly right and
like I love all people but I can't stand
like especially when I'm doing something
trashy like when like somebody tries to
strike up a conversation with you and
McDonald's like you believe they're
taking this longer I was going to Home
Depot and Walmart the other day and like
as we're walking in there's like you
know people behind me like yeah
everyone's everyone's got secret
knowledge you know what I mean that's
that's real garbage behavior it's like
yeah I can't I can't just do what the
sign says dude come on think
exactly exactly that is garbage all
right I want to know take me into the
butterly house now okay all right you're
here close your eyes I know the kids are
getting a little bit older what's the
snack situation at the butterly house
first of all still pop-tarts yeah still
pop-tarts
it's pretty good Wow go ahead sorry yeah
say something else though well I was
gonna ask you about two I was gonna get
into dinner first I was gonna ask like
do you guys have dinner every night
together absolutely we sit down at the
dinner table every single night together
home camiolos almost always a
home-cooked meal my wife's a
stay-at-home mom dude dude this kids all
[ __ ] class stay-at-home mom it didn't
even have to do that
that was the trade-off you brought it
for mayor mr. councilman and comes easy
at home mom dinner's on the table every
night yeah we decided early on we would
be very happy to just be poor but focus
on our kids because we had we started
having kids when we were like 22 didn't
know that we shouldn't do that yeah I
mean accidental accidental kids and I
was I think I was just emulating my dad
every step of the way just doing the
worst possible option for everything but
also being guided by like this inter
poor person righteousness like all
obviously I'm gonna do the right thing
here and raise children in poverty you
are tiered how old are your children now
at the ones did your little girl and
your little boy that I've met back in
the day they're well and 9 12 and 9 and
you have a little one every right we
have a three-year-old that you didn't
meet let me ask you a question okay
settle something for us you sit down
every night you're having dinner okay
what are the kids drinking oh they have
an iced tea
are they having soda what do you give
your kids to drink while they're having
dinner at night sometimes are my son ten
he's nine sometimes he'll have a soda we
limit him on the soda what kind of soda
are we talking uh he's a nerd I got him
into ginger ale that's pretty classy
what what does he drink it with one
pinky in there that's [ __ ] class doll
a nine-year-old drinking ginger ale come
on man I conditioned them so that like
if I let him have a mountain Dew he's
like oh my god it's party time dad dad's
let me [ __ ] party tonight this is so
[ __ ] sick my daughter does not drink
soda she hates how how fizzy it is and
we kept her often at an early age when
they would see me drinking soda if they
were ever like curious about it and they
asked and they wanted some before let me
preface it with this when I was to get
another big fat thing for me powdered
iced tea mix oh you're talking in two
previous Fatso's come on I love when
you're in control don't ya when you got
the scooper bro corporate telling me how
much mix deported no what I knew what I
really loved about the powdered iced tea
mix when you would open it and that
little dust cloud would shoot oblongs
dude if there was enough of it you could
inhale it and then exhale smoke do you
like you could get it it would coat your
lungs on the way in there would be
nowhere else to code it on the way out
so we would exhale mouth-breathing
powdered iced tea mix is my [ __ ] [ __ ]
sometimes just like lifted up an inch
and drop it back on the counter so you
got a second waft that's stewed powdered
iced tea no parents home that's [ __ ]
summertime baby good night so the first
time I got in shape was I realized how
much sugar I was drinking every day of
my life at that point so I tried to keep
my kid I never would have fat kids
because I would just I always feel like
my Hang Ups are primarily from being
poor and fat never one have fat kids and
I just want look at them I don't want to
look at a [ __ ] fact you still here I
sort of got it when I see someone with
like a fat kid I'm just like God dude
that's got to be the worst but they're
so cute and adorable oh I didn't feel
cute and adorable when I was a kid they
don't feel cute and adorable and they
don't grow up to be cute and adorable I
still feel like a physical nuisance
everywhere I go in my breaking chairs
[ __ ] box brings the whole night I
think I shifted the toilet all of a
sudden it was like leaking a little bit
underneath like the ring must be not
placing a floating toilet dude it's not
attached to anything that's the worst we
sit on the toilet you could feel it go
side to side a little bit great do you
don't trust outer seams do my wife just
bought a hammock and went down to the
Hudson and we hung it and she's like do
you want to get in I'm like I was a fat
kid my whole life we do not put
ourselves in position to embarrass
ourselves in public like this in the
comfort of my own home okay
I've never gotten a hammock without my
[ __ ] ass cheeks just scrape him back
and forth around
sure everyone thinks they're [ __ ]
high up so at an early age when when my
daughter tried to try soda I convinced
her it was actually spider milk Wow you
made up okay
she Blake can I try some of that I'd be
like oh you want some my spider milk and
then she goes oh and it just lasted long
enough that she lost any curiosity about
it never had any interest it was a cute
thing I was make my wife laugh like this
little joke right sweater
she'd never got in the soda and a
national [ __ ] athlete it's perfect
we type so what would they drink mostly
growing up water milk apple juice uh the
my daughter did have a chocolate milk
problem for a while dinner
yeah Miller is that's [ __ ] trash yet I
walked him right into that I know is
that poison Foley's is still currently a
big milk for dinner kind of guy I think
my sister still does milk for dinner
that's trash 100% Eve no way around it
she was real big on milk with spaghetti
that's the big thing nobody I hate it
why does this keep coming up on this
podcast everybody does it's awesome it's
so divisive how could you possibly enjoy
that it's insane to me
delish you shouldn't you shouldn't
consume anything with milk that you
wouldn't put in a milk shake that's
pretty good pretty nice everyone that's
a perfect rule that is a perfect what
else you you meatloaf you shouldn't be
drinking doodoo Itza night listen Spyder
milk take it easy
[Laughter]
apple juice that's the trashiest of all
juices we talk about Martinelli's
sparkling stuff I haven't seen him in a
long time but I can tell you from his
answers thus far he is not a
Martinelli's kind of guy no I don't know
Martin now get out with the school with
Steve Moore Nelly [ __ ] Martinelli's
apple juice store breasts store brand
mots was all right no apples apple
juices apple juice is okay but you
shouldn't be drinking milk with [ __ ]
dinner never an apple juice family kids
are stupid man I don't know what to tell
you there's dumb as [ __ ] well we got the
milk thing settle Kip you what else you
got for him I just got one more yeah
all right growing up Endor currently
where you a Bagel Bites or pizza rolls
family I celebrated the entire catalog
I think Bagel Bites might have been like
you know the bills were kind of light
this month sure a staple
these are tight dude do rich people eat
foods that injure your mouth every
single time you eat them I don't think
so because make if they do there would
be they get some because they get some
kind of organic version of it like you
know Amy's pizza nuggets organic you
know yeah I don't know I mean you have
to think like because they were like it
you know any frozen pizza or microwave
you know microwavable or anything it
depends on how long the family's had
money I think because like when you if a
trashy person gets money that just shows
how trashy they can be without limit you
know what I mean so like I don't think
you know like [ __ ] wealthy wealthy
families probably aren't doing [ __ ]
big lights or they're doing them in the
oven for sure the oven definitely on a
toaster oven or microwave yeah we do
grownup had like they knew exactly the
time that they would put it because at
the time for each microwave was
different every what's on the box
I'm sure there's a million 90s bits
about that microwave Bagel Bites like
yeah dude
and with the pizza rolls they were in
the middle they were ice cold up until
like a perfect like it had to be like
three minutes and four seconds at 305
they were the surface of the Sun yeah
yeah and at 303 they're frozen still can
I say something
shoot guess it's gonna sound real trashy
my move was always to try to shoot to
get them a little bit underdone because
when you bit into the nuclear hot part
if there was a little frozen piece left
inside it would cool your mouth down so
you went medium-rare he throws an
aristocrat is ultimate seriously I think
having any any kind of nuanced opinion
about this food at all is gross 100% but
that's what this whole podcast is
exactly what's my life about hot pockets
to have a nice little cold cold spot in
the pocket just just to cool you down
halfway through depending what kind of
pocket it was for sure that's a
dangerous game you bite into a mouths
coaling hot pocket you're like I know
there's a cold front if I get a little
bit deeper in yeah and you know
sometimes gonna turn it around in your
mouth you want it even what kind of
frozen pizzas did you do growing up and
now I I considered Elios like a blessing
okay I was back to Elios recently they
hold up as far as Oh [ __ ] hell for
the whole quarantine yeah we're big
Elias family but grown up in in the
Philly and and it's probably true in
most cities we didn't do a lot of frozen
pizzas because you were never more than
that 30-second walk from a slice 75 cent
or a dollar slice so I you know anytime
I got a dollar I was like sick I'm gonna
go eat pizza did you guys have any hot
candies when you grow up like very like
cool like I remember at one point we had
the watermelon shaped lollipops hit the
scene near my son I don't remember those
oh you mean I thought you meant spicy no
oh yeah dude I do come on dude nice more
handy yeah and some warheads what do you
remember when warheads hit and when
[ __ ] airheads hit and like you had to
have them in sleep everybody in school
was having them and went if you could
get the white kind of airhead that was I
knew with likes you would act them down
into the corner you would never do that
like shake them and it all moves in
there like a ball no it turns into a
bite-sized if you take the end of an air
hits thing and shake it it'll slide all
the way down into the one end of the
wrapper that sounds like that's a bit
like a gusher kind of little flavor bomb
yeah that's it
we had these gummy candies I think they
might have been Ninja Turtles but they
came in like a clear individually
wrapped clear plastic tray and you peel
the back off and ate them
those were a staple and then yeah you
know talking about yeah and I know
you're talking about with the watermelon
slices they also have different flavors
but those were [ __ ] huge those yeah I
was a kid I was a child of the 80s man
and all [ __ ] happen
those were uh those watermelon lollipops
hit us around the time that kids started
like making out and I was just out in
the cold on both what they were like a
quarter you couldn't get a couple bro
first of all you had to ration your
quarters my parents I think my person
sent me school with like 50 cents or it
was like exact change for an Arctic
splash iced tea I was just gonna ask for
an Arctic splash kid yeah I mean that's
first of all if you started the entire
podcast with Arctic splash it would have
been over for me but uh yeah that an
individual pretzel
I remember going down to my cousin's and
hold on that was lunch no that was like
they had snack time at school and you
had to pay for snacks it was a Catholic
school and bastards Yeah right
it brought around a pretzel tray you
bought your pretzel and you know that's
so trash that that's what they go around
and Philadelphia schools with [ __ ]
saw Arctic splats like horse feed we
would go to them at the corner store cuz
we would come in from the suburbs to go
to my cousin's house in Port Richmond so
like a corner store was like crazy for
us you wanted mom yeah you can walk to
go get candy and snacks
that's ultimate childhood autonomy oh
yeah dude for sure for sure so we walk
in I remember it was yeah goals on goal
and [ __ ] ongoing Allegheny and do
when they closed they were like we're
closing and our Arctic splash was like
no long they were there something was
happening to a fight she head down with
crates to buy all the Arctic splash in
the [ __ ] store that's how [ __ ]
Garvey we're I have I have an Arctic
splash in a ziplock bag on top of my
fridge that I had signed by a UFC former
UFC lightweight champion Eddie Alvarez
jeez grow up in the neighborhood and he
was doing a signing at like a metro
yes around the corner from my house so I
walked around I got into sign in Arctic
splash and now I have it I forgot to
empty it so now like the liquid like
made the thing swell in the heat it's
it's it's gross I said well you're
banking on for the down payment on the
new organs at my state quarters yeah
it's taking place in the quarters oh my
god tymberlee buddy this has been
absolutely amazing Kippy what's your
what's your verdict here trash for sure
I mean there's no way around it he was
was we grew up wait rash here but he's
making it you know he made a a made a
right turn he's raising a good family's
got a stay-at-home wife you know what I
mean she's his wife's got a [ __ ]
Volkswagen that he needs a woman he's a
front-end da yeah he's moving moving
towards class for sure absolutely fam
you're all class but early you're all
class here good man um anything you want
the folks out there to know other than
to make sure that they check out the dad
meat podcast with Tim but early and Mike
Ranney no man it's just really great to
spend some time with you guys seriously
I mean I mean this would have been
fabulous without recording it
congratulations on all your success
congratulations of moving the [ __ ]
gas you too buddy thank you very much I
appreciate that I I've had the pleasure
of following you guys all the way from
Philly and I I mean the the the effort
and creative what would you call it
you've made you've made something very
distinct and it's been really cool to
watch it grow and I got to see the work
that you put in before are you garbage
and it's all been leading to this and I
just I don't know man it's I I'm just
happy to be here with you guys for but
thank you so much no problem man
you're good man buddy thank you so much
for playing thank you so much for being
on gang make sure you check out the dead
meat podcast follow Tim butterly axe on
Twitter yeah I'm Tim but early on
everything that's one very nice make
sure you check him out watch you're the
best Thank You Kippy what do you got
just that kevin ryan comedy on all
social media and also if you haven't
already
please rate review subscribe on iTunes
and also full video available on YouTube
you can subscribe there thanks for
listening yes sorry in gang please do us
a favor come along with us to the gas
digital network if you want to sign up
for gas digital you can use promo code a
yg and you'll get a dollar 50 off your
subscription and we get a 14-day free
trial use promo code a yg we are so
excited for the move and we will see you
guys next week
yep please